who Anna Kendrick and Blake Lively
seeing isn't necessarily believing when
it comes to their new thriller a simple
favor and as we're getting found out I'm
their co-stars past and present can be a
bit of a challenge to in honor of one of
the posters where you just see eyes at
the top we're going to play a simple
co-stars hello and show you eyes from
people that you know you have worked
with there we go
all right oh and I have a sides come on
it's amazing my star what it's an easy
one Ryan worked with Anna in the voices
and wife Blake in Green Lantern trick
question and I worked with Blake Paul
and Henry in you guessed it a simple
favor which hits theaters September 14th
every time we do this I feel so high
tone green eyes you both have worked
with name starts with a B then worked
with an ax in the accountant and with
Blake in the town oh my god those baby
blues who is it mm-hmm hold it singer
actor oh is it
yes and Justin worked with Anna in the
animated film trolls
you're so right okay celebrities
eyebrows yeah you need the eyebrows
well actually we googled it and look
what we found
I used to look exactly the same without
their eyebrows we don't always like link
it all no no it looked a little bit like
Anna but like this oh I know I wouldn't
know mm-hmm did he die Ralph
[Music]
[Applause]